du fait de temps de formation des
enseignants sur le temps de la classe
pour ce qui est des absences qu'on ne
peut pas éviter il y en aura évidemment
toujours dans une administration 1200000
agents il nous faut améliorer notre
capacité de remplacement c'est donc pour
répondre à votre deuxième question sur
le pacte enseignant puisque vous savez
le pacte vise à mieux rémunérer mieux
soutenir les les enseignants qui
s'engagent notamment dans le
remplacement de courte durée il y en a
déjà beaucoup qui s'engageaient dans le
remplacement de courte durée euh ces
années précédentes en heures
supplémentaires ils seront désormais
rémunérés 50 % de plus pour ces missions
qu'ils effectuaient déjà jusqu'à l'année
dernière un enseignant qui faisait du
remplacement de courte durée était
rémunéré je crois 41 € brut de l'heure
avec le pacte enseignant ça passe à 70 €
brut de l'heure augmentation très
importante qui a vocation à ce qu'il y
ait évidemment davantage de remplacement
pour ces cours qui sont sinon perdus
pour pour les élèves vous m'inrogé sur
la le déploiement du PACT j'ai eu
l'occasion de communiquer sur des
premiers chiffres mais qui sont vraiment
très préliminaire parce qu'il date de la
fin du mois de septembre plutôt la
deuxème début de la 2è moitié de
septembre que toutes les académies n'ont
pas pu nous les faire remonter et que
vous le savez le recours au Pact dépend
beaucoup des protocoles sur le
remplacement signés dans chaque
établissement et que tous les
établissements n'avaient pas signer leur
protocole et pourtant un enseignant sur
quat s'est engagé dans le pacte c'est
même un sur TR au collège et un sur TR
au lycée professionnel ce qui est quand
même assez loin euh des prévisions
parfois
on va dire terrible qui était faite
notamment par certains observateurs ou
certaines organisations syndicales moi
je veux les remercier évidemment de
Cêtre engagé dans le pacte enseignant
j'aurai l'occasion d'avoir un nouveau
bilan chiffré sur le pacte au retour des
vacances de la toussin et évidemment je
répondrai aux questions que vous aurez
sur ce sujet ma deuxième priorité c'est
de bâtir une école des droits et devoirs
c'est d'abord un devoir de
reconnaissance que nous avons et que
j'ai comme ministre vis-à-vis de tous
ceux qui font vivre l'école cela passe
en grande partie par la rémun ération en
la matière là aussi nous tenons nos
engagements en cette rentrée les
professeurs sont rémunérés entre 125 et
250 € net de plus par mois qu'à la
rentrée précédente septembre 2022
septembre 2023 et ce sans condition il y
a eu deux revalorisation du point
d'indice une revalorisation socle en
cette rentrée ça fait entre 125 et 250 €
nets de plus par mois entre septembre 22
et septembre 23 pour les professeurs
néotitulaires qui démarrent dans
l'enseignement ils sont désormais
rémunérés 2100 € nets par mois c'est
même 2466 € en Rep plus avec ces
revalorisation inédite nous
effaçons en grande partie une génération
de déclassement salarial pour nos
professeurs et nous revenons exprimer en
point de Smic à un niveau de
rémunération supérieur par rapport à
celui de l'an 2000 c'est la plus forte
augmentation de salaire dans l'éducation
nationale depuis des décennies j'entends
évidemment qu'il y a en grande partie du
rattrapage justement de ces dernières
décennies j'entends que pour un certain
nombre dans enseignant c'est encore
difficile mais enfin il me semble
important de reconnaître qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'équivalent ces 30 dernières années
d'augmentation salariale dans
l'éducation nationale que ce que nous
avons fait euh euh c'est depuis la
réélection du président de la République
depuis la réélection du président en
2022 entre mi-2022 et janvier 2024
puisque que vous savez qu'il y a une
dernière mesure en janvier 2024 avec
l'injection de 5 point d'indice majorés
pour tous les fonctionnairees mais qui
bénéficiera aussi au enseignants si on
met bout à bout ces mesures entre avril
2022 et janvier 2024 c'est plus 11 % au
global en moyenne de revalorisation ce
devoir de reconnaissance nous le devons
également aux aesh qui accompagne chaque
jour les élèves en situation de handicap
dans leur scolarité en cette rentrée
plus de la moitié des aesh sont
désormais en CDI ce qui marque notre
volonté forte de déprécariser ce métier
l'an dernier on était à peine en dessous
de 30 % d'aesh en CDI par ailleurs toute
bénéficie d'une revalorisation de 10 à
13 %. évidemment si on veut
structurellement et véritablement
améliorer la rémunération des aesh c'est
sur le temps de travail qu'il faut jouer
si vous êtes à 24 heur maximum par
semaine pour améliorer votre
rémunération il faut évidemment
augmenter le volume horaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous travaillons
évidemment avec les collectivités
locales sur le temps périscolaire nous
travaillons aussi dans les suites de la
Conférence nationale du handicap sur des
missions supplémentaires qui pourraent
être confié aux aesh pour leur permettre
d'avoir un temps complet et donc une
meilleure rémunération mais nous
attendons pas ce travail pour faire une
revalorisation
nous poursuivons également l'effort de
recrutement à l'heure où je vous parle
nos effectifs et nos écoles comptent
15000 àes de plus qu'à la rentrée 2022
l'école des droits et devoirs c'est
aussi le respect de l'autorité du maître
et de l'autorité des savoirs c'est le
respect des principes les plus
élémentaires de notre République comme
la laïcité ces derniers mois nous le
savons les atteintes à la laïcité
s'étaient développé à un rythme
inquiétant que cela concerne la
contestation des enseignements en
histoire géographie en SVT ou dans
d'autres disciplines ou bien sûr le port
de tenue non conforme à la loi de 2004
vous le savez j'ai assumé une décision
importante au moment de ma nomination
une décision importante mais qui en
réalité n'aurait pas dû être vécu comme
telle puisqu'il s'agit simplement de
décider d'appliquer la loi la loi de
2004 ce qu' a confirmé le Conseil d'État
dans son avis qui a été remis suite aux
référés qui ont été conduit par
certaines associations sur ma décision
le Conseil d'État a confirmé que je ne
faisais qu'appliquer la loi de 2004 vous
m'avez interroger monsieur le Président
sur la manière dont cette mesure s'est
appliquée je suis je le dis très
satisfait de la manière dont cette
mesure a été
appliqué nous avons eu sur la première
semaine de la rentrée scolaire autour
d'un millier de contestation de la règle
par des élèves ce qui est peu par
rapport au nombre de tenu noncformes qui
étaient porté l'année dernière ce qui
montre qu'une grande partie des élèves
concernés s'était conformé à la règle
pour le jour de la rentrée et surtout
dans la quasi totalité des cas nous
sommes parvenus par la pédagogie et le
dialogue à régler ces situations et moi
je vraiment rendre hommage aux chefs
d'établissement à leurs équipes aux
équipes laïité valeur de la République
des rectorats qui étaient au côté des
chefs d'établissement pour engager ce
dialogue et cette pédagogie avec les
élèves et les familles pour moi ça
montre que quand il y a de la pédagogie
du dialogue bref de l'humain on arrive à
gérer des situations tendues et c'est
pour moi un enseignement y compris que
je porte pour la question du harcèlement
scolaire ma troisème priorité c'est
enfin de construire une école qui
émancipe et qui rend heureux s'émancip
c'est pour nos élèves la chance
d'acquérir une autonomie d'esprit un
esprit critique une ouverture
intellectuelle à tous les savoirs et au
monde cette émancipation passe d'abord
par l'enseignement des humanités et de
la culture générale c'est pourquoi nous
étendons à tous les collégiens l'accès
aux paseculture alors que plus de la
moitié des élèves de 4e et de 3e ont pu
bénéficier l'an passé d'une activité à
ce titre visiter un musée avec avec un
guide conférencier assister à une
représentation au théâtre pratiquer un
instrument de musique autant de
découvertes et de pratiques qui font
l'éducation artistique et culturelle de
notre jeunesse et que nous développons
en cette rentrée encore grâce à
l'extension du passeculture collectif à
l'école nous allons également refonder
pour la rentrée prochaine l'enseignement
moral et civique j'y tiens tout
particulièrement l'école doit non
seulement élever le niveau mais former
des républicains pour cela mon
prédécesseur a saisi le Conseil
supérieur des programmes qui me rendra
ses propositions iici la fin de l'année
je veillerai tout particulièrement à la
place de nos institutions dans cet
enseignement à l'enseignement de la
laïcité et je sais Monsieur le Président
que la mission que vous conduisez sera
très utile là aussi pour enrichir ce
travail là avec le sujet de la BAA
évidemment on n' pas réglé tous les
sujets d'application de la laïcité à
l'école loin de là je rappelle que dans
les récentes études encore un enseignant
sur deux déclare s'autocensuré notamment
pour des raisons de contestation de la
laïcité doit donc poursuivre et
j'attends beaucoup de la mission qui est
conduite par les sénatrices et les
sénateurs sur ce sujet je veux avancer
aussi sur l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information dont nous percevons chaque
jour l'utilité face aux tentations de
l'instantanée et de l'immédiateté qui ne
remplaceront jamais l'esprit critique et
le débat éclairé l'objectif est que dès
la rentrée prochaine nous puissions
doubler le temps dédié à l'enseignement
moral et civique dès la 5e enfin je ne
saurais parler des droits et devoirs ou
d'une école qui rend heureux sans parler
du droit à absolu pour chaque élève de
la République d'être en paix à l'école
oui le devoir du politique est de
garantir à chaque élève une scolarité
sereine je veux bien sûr parler du fléo
que représente le harcèlement scolaire
qui a déjà fait souffrir trop de nos
enfants et de leur famille parfois
jusqu'à
l'irréparable chaque élève a le droit à
la parole chaque élève a le droit à
l'écoute chaque élève a le droit d'être
protégé voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
et avec lui j'en suis sûr une très large
majorité des membres du Parlement font
de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyberharcèlement une
cause absolument prioritaire pour notre
école j'en ai fait en tout cas ma grande
cause pour l'école et je n'accepterai
pas qu'on oppose cette priorité là aux
autres que j'ai évoqué précédemment peut
pas imaginer élever le niveau si on a
des centaines de milliers ou des
millions d'élèves qui sont malheureux à
l'école quand vous êtes harcelé le
harcèlement envahit totalement votre
esprit il n a